astérix et obélix en chair et en os
enfin presque l'incarnation des deux
célèbres gaulois sur grand écran est
sans doute l'une des sorties de films
les plus attendus de ce début d'année
qui ne connaît en effet ces deux héros
de bande dessinée leur appétit de romain
et de sangliers leur goût pour la farce
et la résistance on s'attend donc à une
superproduction et on sera servi
mercredi avec ce film l'un des plus
chers du cinéma français carine shana
philippe hernando par pitié ne rentrait
pas dans une intrigue où l'on y voit
cette potion magique ça les rend
invincibles ils vont goûter en paix d'un
côté des irréductibles gaulois qui
boivent de la potion magique et de
l'autre des romains qui boivent
irrémédiablement le bouillon et même
défie les lois de la pesanteur
en attendant que le ciel leur tombe sur
la tête les créatures de papier d'uderzo
et goscinny sont donc dorénavant en
chair et en os
apparemment sans déboires c'est tout à
fait naturel que je fasse obélix puisque
c'est pas tellement par l'appétit mais
c'est par l'énergie je puis ceux de
faire un obélix amoureux à l'ofev bon
mais enfin régime c'est-à-dire produire
manger 300 billets leur manque plus que
deux et ça c'est joli chacun
connaît très très bien le visage afrique
puisque c'est dessiner alors que tout
mon problème a été d'essayer de lui
ressembler donc on a travaillé beaucoup
pendant deux mois deux mois d'essai il a
dit exactement au belux par toutatis
sauvé des biens obélix saül dja est
vraiment sûr mais on trinque estime
musclé 200 plans d'effets spéciaux
plutôt renversant et un budget digne
d'hollywood près de 280 millions de
francs
c'est aussi l'ambiance dans le village
qui était magique selon cet observateur
privilégié du tournage celui là il
entraîna une vie collective
extraordinaire puisqu'il ya tout le
monde vivait là et quand les acteurs
avaient fini de tourner il rentrait pas
dans leurs caravanes
il restait à côté des opérateurs pour
parler avec des figurants pour parler
entre eux le film les avaient pénétré
effet d'une bande dessinée une vente
d'atr animé du même plaisir d'un musée